me
医師の
ます
ていました
皆様こんにちは
林氏がミスと申しますよろしくお願い致します
皆様は
手の形で声が変わることをご存知でしょうか
よかったです知っていると言われるとをやれることが何もありません
お手を拝借いたします
っての形をグーにしてください
手の形をグーにしていただき深呼吸をしますはいどうぞ
楽にしてください
深呼吸をしたとき体のどこが活発に動きましたでしょうか
もう一度深呼吸をしますはいどうぞ
楽にしてください
体のどこが活発に動きましたでしょうか
そうです
胸の筋肉が活発に動きます
次に
小指と薬指を折り曲げてください
小指と薬指を折り曲げてくださいたまに親指と人差し指を折り曲げている方がいます
目で確認していただいて結構です小指と薬指を折り曲げてください
深呼吸をしますはいどうぞ
[音楽]
楽にしてください
体のどこが活発に動きましたでしょうか
もう一度深呼吸をしますはいどうぞ
[音楽]
楽にしてください
体のところが活発に動きましたでしょうか
そうです
お腹の筋肉が活発に動きます
手の形で何が変わってくるのか息を入れるときに使う筋肉の場所が変わってきます
使う筋肉の場所が変わってくると声述べ方も変わってきます
それが一つ試してみたいと思います
これから椅子に座っている私さんを起こしたいと思います
私さんは起こされ前としてくださいを越されてしまったら僕に後で重曹を1本ご馳走し
て下さいね
僕はこれから皆様にお伝えした手の形で行いますまず空間でいきます
空をつくって深呼吸をします
相手を床へ手を入れていきます一成
ので
どんな声ですっ
詰まった声が出てきます不安定な可愛いですした次に小指と薬指を折り曲げます
そして深呼吸をします
いきます一成
のでどんな声ですか
安定さ柔らかな声でなぜか起こすこともできます
打ち合わせ通りですありがとうございます
さてこれをぜひ皆様一緒にご体感していただきたいと思いますどうぞお渡し下さいませ
ん
を断ちいただき
2人一組になってくださいお隣さんと目が合った方と
2人一組になってください目が合わなければ目を合わせてください
2人一組になっていただきましたらお一人は椅子におかけください
もう一人は立っていてください
さあ椅子に座っている方
起こされまいとしてくださいを越されてしまったら後でジュースをご馳走してあげて
ください
はい
スペースバック取りながらねやっていってくださいさああたっている方一緒にやって
いきましょう
だっている方っての形をグーにしてください
深呼吸をしますはいすって
はいてい
そして相手のところへ手を入れて
ので
息が詰まるの分かりますか猫の体の状態を覚えておいてください
さあそうしましたら次になっている方
小指と薬指を折り曲げてください
小指と薬指を折り曲げてくださいそして深呼吸をしますはいすってー
はいて
相手のところに手を入れて
いっせーのではい
素晴らしい
皆さん打ち合わせ通りありがとうございますハイポー対してくださいに座ってた方が
今度お立ちください
さあ座っている方
起こされまいとしてくださいね
を越されてしまったら今度ワインを1杯1本ごちそうしてあげてください
ダイバーがありました気を付けて下さい
さあ飼っている方一緒にやっていきましょう手の形をグーにしてください
手の形をグーにしていただき深呼吸をします
はいすってー
相手
相手のところに手を入れて
いっせーので
息が詰まるのわかりますでしょうかねお腹に力が入ってくる
この身体の状態を覚えておいてください
さあそうしましたら当たっている方
小指と薬指を折り曲げてくださいあっている方
小指と薬指を折り曲げてください
深呼吸をしますはいステイ
配点
相手の男に手を入れて
1世のでしょ
は ce
ありがとうございます
どうぞおかけくださいませ
いやーこれだけ多くの方々と打ち合わせするを大変でしたねありがとうございます
人前でお話をするときに声が詰まってしまう
震えてしまう
あがり症吃音症の方々ぜひこの小指と薬指を折り曲げておくと声が安定して出てきて
くれます詰まらず
ので小指と薬指を折り曲げてステージへ歩いていって
そしてお辞儀をすると
押すとこの状態で言うと
片方の手だけで構いません
片方のても小指と薬指が近ければいいです手のひらに
この3本よりも
小指と薬指があっ手のひらに近ければいいですこの3本よりも
なのでここまで伸ばす必要はありませんこのぐらいで十分効果はあります
そしてもう片方の手で覆ってしまえば
問題はありません
さあもう一つ違うことを行います私さんお願いします
声どうぞ
足幅を肩幅より少し広めにとってください
転倒予防ですこれから湯だします
私さんは戦っていただくだけで結構です
私さん苦手な食べ物は何ですか
卵はい
タコ卵は思い浮かべてください
この身体の状態ですねはい私の好きな食べ物は何ですか
やっ
すき焼きはいっ
ちなみにじゃあすき焼き煮玉子は使わない
使われば分かりましたはい
すき焼きを思い浮かべてください
[音楽]
これで体が安定しますもう一度卵を思い浮かべてください
いっぱいでオッケーですはい
これをぜひまた皆様体感していただきたいと思いますどうぞお出し下さいませ
先ほどのペアになってください
先ほどのペアになっていただき1人は前を1人は後ろへお願いします前後の関係です
仲がよくて向き合いたいの分かりませんあの同じ方向を向いてください
前の片足幅を少し広めにとってください
転倒予防ですこれから後ろの方がね
重い覚え存分ここぞとばかり裏していただいて結構ですあとでね
さあ枚の方
ただ立っていただくだけで結構税
前の方苦手なものを一つ思い浮かべてください
苦手な食べ物苦手な動物苦手な人苦手な言葉
苦手なものを前の一つ思い浮かべてください
決まりましたでしょうか
苦手なものを一つ思い浮かべてください
さあ後ろの方揺らしてください
この身体の状態を覚えておいてください
サーバーの方
好きな食べ物好きな動物ペット好きな景色
好きな言葉前の方好きなものを一つ思い浮かべてください
決まりましたでしょうか好きなものを一つ思い浮かべてください
後ろの方揺らしてください
お妙さんいただけたようですそうしましたら毎年の交代してください
さあ枚の方たち幅を肩幅よりやや広めにとってください
転倒予防です
後ろの方先ほど狩りがあります存分に行かせていただいたということです
さあ前の方苦手なものを一つ思い浮かべてください
苦手な食べ物苦手な動物苦手な人苦手な言葉
苦手なものを一つ思い浮かべてください
思い浮かべててください
後ろの方いらしてください
この身体の状態を覚えておいてくださいね
サーバへの方
好きなものを一つ思い浮かべてください
好きな食べ物好きな動物ペット好きな人を好きな景色
好きな言葉
好きなものを一つ思い浮かべてください
思い浮かべててください
後ろの方いらしてください
はいご体感いただけた様ですあれ
がとうございますどうぞおかけください
[拍手]
ああいう形ずご体感いただけたようです
体の使い方と思考の使い方の組み合わせで声を使うパフォーマンス
声を使う表現話す読む歌うことのパフォーマンスが安定してきます
本日みなさまにお伝えしたことでいきますと体の使い方が
手の形
思考の使い方が好きなものを一つ思い浮かべるです
これを取り入れて挨拶をしてみます
皆様こんにちは早瀬茂みすと申しますよろしくお願い致します
変わりましたでしょうか
本日みなさまにお伝えしたかったことをお伝えすることができました
是非試して日常生活で使ってください
本日はご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]